it's what this program night after
tonight we call for equal justice under
the law whether it's the Russian
investigation any criminal matter no
person no matter how privileged rich
entitled connected should receive any
special treatment
from our government now sadly that is
not the case with the Clintons for
example you might remember when James
Comey admitted under oath that then
Attorney General Loretta Lynch asked him
to call the investigation into Clinton's
email server scandal not an
investigation don't call it an
investigation call it a matter and he
listened to her what's US the Clinton
campaign at the time was using all kinds
of euphemisms security review matters
things like that for what was going on
we were getting to a place where the
eternal and I were both gonna have to
testify and talk publicly about it and I
want to know was she gonna authorize us
to confirm we had an investigation and
she said yes but don't call it that call
it a matter and I said why would I do
that and she said just call it a matter
just follow the Clinton talking points
of course you're the up bad director I'm
the Attorney General the fixes in here
now is the author of defeating jihad
former deputy assistant to the president
Sebastian Walker and the attorney the
person representing that FBI informant
in the uranium one scandal Victoria ton
singh is back with us all right all
right he not only said followed Loretta
Lynch's advice Sebastian he also then
went forward with the matter and the fix
was in
he purpose gross negligence that is a
legal term it was in not one but at
least two documents they edited it out
to get the legal standard gone so that
they could exonerate her before they
even did the investigation I've never
heard of such insider backroom dealing
in my life you'd be in jail Victoria
would be well Victoria would never be in
jail because she has Joe and I'd be in
jail your thoughts may mortals like you
and I Shawn yes we'd be in jail I spent
15 years of my life leave living in the
former dictatorship of Hungary and and
this is worse than the stuff I saw there
living in a country that had been a
dictatorship for forty years there's a
fact pattern Victoria is the legal
professional
but even I can see the fact pattern
there are key individuals a Comey mauler
McCabe Rosenstein and it's clear that
these individuals thought Hillary was
going to win all of these people are
buddies they stick together they watch
each other's back and they did what they
thought would guarantee their future
under a Hillary Whitehouse the the the
wrong candidate one and we see what we
see today and I'll share one thing with
movies Sean that I haven't said before
on television I tried for six months to
work with the FBI out of the White House
on a specific project the FBI at the
highest level blocked me at the end of
the day I had a senior FBI agents say
the following thing to me he said
Sebastian you need to understand the 7th
floor of the FBI meaning the senior
leadership looks at the Trump White
House as the enemy
each night that's how bad it is Sean
Victoria if the fix is in and he's
writing the exoneration before he's done
his investigation if he takes Loretta
Lynch's cue she of course met with Bill
Clinton on the tarmac and then he
changes the standard from gross
negligence which is the legal standard
how could any person conclude anything
other then the fix was in just like she
rigged the election just like she tried
to rig the general election she'll Brig
the primary she tried to do it with the
fake Russian lie propaganda dossier
there's a lot of fixing going on here
well yeah but Sean gross negligence is
the statutory term but I can tell you
extremely careless is also a legal term
and as Greg said earlier on your show it
would be synonymous and a judge would
explain that to it to a jury so it was a
little too cute by far and then as you
said Comey accepted calling the
investigation a matter and and where was
Comey after that tarmac meeting if I had
been FBI director I would have called in
every agent FBI agent on her detail and
asked them how that meeting came about
and what was the timing and what were
they responsible for and what orders
were they given I don't think that's
been done
yes let me where was commies inner moral
code let me tell you a story about him
when he was Deputy Attorney General and
lawyers would argue with him at the
Justice Department he would turn to them
and say I think your moral compass is
askew well let me tell you whose moral
compass is askew James Comey
let me get an update from you on uranium
one the FBI informed who had a muzzle on
him an NDA on him you've been able to
get that lifted now the uranium one deal
sold out of security we import uranium
why we would ever give 20% to Russia and
when they knew in 2009 Muller knew Eric
Holder had to know they're with the FBI
the FBI director and the head of the
Justice Department bribery kickbacks
extortion money laundering and
racketeering
how could they have not stopped that who
I mean who was going to stop it it seems
like Obama wasn't going to stop and even
though the FBI was telling the informant
that the president was being briefed on
this investigation the meaning Obama yes
the President Obama's getting briefed on
this investigation and he was in other
words through the presidential daily
briefing
what will you your client this informant
who has documents emails tape recordings
and infiltrated for all that period of
time what will he tell us what will the
country learn oh you know you've done
this before and I'm not going to tell
you yet he doesn't have the gag order
but this is a time that I am working
with him in organizing his presentation
and I'm not about to reveal reveal it
the people working very hard will it be
historic well I think it will be very
informative about what okay at the time
that's why you were gonna learn dr. Gork
I got to ask you this Donna Brazile
saying the primary was fixed hillary
owned the DNC so she used the DNC to
funnel money through a lawyer to pay for
the phony Russian information she used
her campaign to pay the lawyer to
funneled us this phony Russian
information to rig and fix the general
election where's the mccullars country
when when when all of this this is a
house
cards that is collapsing the DNC the
Clinton scandal after scandal when
everything comes out in the wash I think
we will find we will be shocked and we
will find that the Clinton corruption
this cartel will make Al Capone look
like a guy that took your lunch money
from the the cattle futures on down
right through to Benghazi right through
to uranium one the Clintons have been a
decades-long crime cartel and the
uranium one scandal is the biggest 20%
of our uranium let's just let that sink
in nuclear weapons radiological medicine
all of that given to Vladimir Putin it
beggars belief Sean I can tell you on
charge yeah real quick you have a second
for me to make one point what the
Clintons are successful because they try
to ruin anybody who opposes him watch
what's gonna happen to Donna Brazile
you'll be able to do clips all day
tomorrow about people who are saying oh
she doesn't know what she was doing
Donna Brazile is a tough cookie she used
to even hang around with some of us
Republican women years I've known her
for years she talks she's very yeah
she's gonna take him on there is more
than I can tell tonight that I know
tick-tock stay tuned we got a lot more
coming good thank you both for being
with us when we